So the developer and
I have written all of these rules.
Good job by the way, and
the rules are in the app.
>> Well that's a load off my
shoulders while I get packed.
>> Wait up.
You didn't let me finish my sentence.
All of your hulabaloo about
security has me paranoid.
>> You're welcome.
>> Mm.
>> Okay.
Okay.
I guess it is my fault you're
on this security kick.
What's the problem?
>> Here I'll walk you through it.
Our decision to use email as the key for
the user is causing a lot of issues.
This boils down to the fact that
the only secure and verified method for
knowing who a person is in the security
rules, is using the off dot UID.
You don't automatically have any sort
of email associated with the account.
And this is of course why we made
our mapping node from UID to email.
Unfortunately, this connection here
is a very hard thing to secure.
Let me walk you through an example.
So, we have our hacker here.
She has no sort of special permissions
to access our Firebase app.
But she is JavaScript and
Firebase savvy,
so she could execute some arbitrary
JavaScript code on our app.
And she could write pretty much
any JavaScript code that she likes
as long as our database rules permit
her to either do the read or the right.
So let's take a look at the rules
that we have right now for
the UID mapping node.
Our rules say that anyone logged in can
read a single UID from the UID mappings
node and if you are the user
who's associated with that node,
you can write data to it.
As long as you're adding data for
the first time.
And we further have a validate rule
just to make sure that the value is
in the form of the encoded email.
Okay.
So the first thing that our hacker could
do is execute a create account command.
The first issue that
I'm seeing here is that
since she's doing this
outside of our Android app.
She could basically bypass
that whole nice reset password
logon flow that we have.
So there's nothing that's really forcing
her to prove that she actually owns
the email that she claims that she owns.
But she calls this create user command.
And this should work.
The Firebase backend will
return to her a you UID.
So now she has a UID that she
has legitimate access to.
So, here's a sample of a UID mappings
table, and the question is, is there
anything in the rules that stops the
hacker from making an entry like this?
Basically an entry where she uses
the legitimate UID that she got for
herself and then associates it
with some email such as my email.
>> No I guess not.
After all the only rule is that
they're adding an entry associate with
their own user and that's a new entry.
So yes, that seems bad, but
what does it mean for the app?
>> It means terrible, terrible things.
Here, let's take a look at the database.
Literally every rule trusts
that the UID mapping
tells you what email
the UID is associated with.
So if we can hack that mapping it
essentially gives our hacker complete
access to all of my shopping lists.
And that's a pretty major issue.
So again,
issue number one is that there's
not really a real way to
enforce our reset login flow
if somebody is executing code outside of
the Shopping List plus plus Android app.
And issue number two is that with
just a little bit of JavaScript code
a hacker could easily
impersonate another user.
And that's because our UID mappings
table is currently insecure and
it's actually pretty tricky or
potentially impossible to
secure in our security rules.
>> And you're launching version .5 when?
>> In a week.
[SOUND]
>> Sweet Nexus that's my ride
to the airport.
Okay, I'll tell you what.
I think I can ask Puff to chat with you.
He's actually in the SF office today and
might be able to swing by your office.
Well, that's actually
incredibly convenient.
And my cribbage match got
rescheduled so, awesome.
>> Well then I'll tell
him to take the company.
Two person man experimental
flying electric vehicle.
>> Excellent.
Thanks JP and safe travels.